[Music]
right now congress is debating a 120
billion dollar bailout of the restaurant
industry
some of america's best known chefs are
supporting the proposal
six million of the 23 million people who
lost a job early in the pandemic
worked in the food and beverage industry
errol barnett talked to some of those
several restaurant owners rather about
their fight to stay afloat errol good
morning
good morning look this is how bad things
are this time last week the restaurant
you see behind me it's
called fonda it's a mexican restaurant
it was open
after suffering through the pandemic
offering delivery takeout
and setting up in-street dining but the
owner told me she had to close
permanently just a few days ago because
she couldn't get a break on rent
and that story is repeating itself
millions of times over all throughout
the country
so now some influential figures are
pressing congress
to help once crowded and full of life
bars and restaurants are now struggling
to survive
a bar as a setting just leads to a
transmission and amid coronavirus spikes
state restrictions have made it
challenging for more than a million
establishments
across the country to stay open we do
not want to shut down
ohio bars and restaurants
that would be devastating to them
where's the people
carolina gutierrez and a husband run
arapazos with two locations in central
ohio
downtown is like a ghost town you know i
think it's the buildings are about
occupy about less than 50 percent and we
depend
on the business people especially here
in the in the downtown area
even after laying off staff and ramping
up takeout
gutierrez fears she will not be able to
afford her 8 000
a month rent in downtown columbus the
landlord wants
needs to get his money but if i'm not if
i'm down 50 percent
60 percent how am i going to come up
with that money you know
i mean when i think about it's just as
scary because our name is on it so that
means
you know he can put a lien in my house
he can go after us
one recent report predicts up to 230
000 restaurants could permanently close
by the end of the year
16 million people risk losing their jobs
to establish a lifeline the newly formed
independent restaurant coalition
launched this ad this week urging
congress to act
without your help our favorite places to
eat
will be gone forever how bad are things
right now for the restaurant industry
uh you know right now things are pretty
bad for the restaurant industry even if
restaurants are allowed to eat
allowed to open at 50 capacity we're not
doing 50
of the business chef and tv host tom
colicchio is just one of the voices
supporting the restaurants act
a bipartisan proposal which would
provide 120 billion dollars
to help small and mid-sized eateries
this is
everything that that will give us the
necessary lifeline to get through this
period
but also to get slightly past here and
get open and so
when we finally do have a vaccine and
when the country finally opens up and
people feel comfortable coming back
we'll have restaurants to get back to
without government help you know we just
can't stay afloat
chef nina compton has laid off nearly
100 people at her two restaurants in new
orleans
but she says the impact is felt far
beyond her doors
this is about the farmer that provides
me beautiful uh produce
this is about the fishermen that give me
beautiful shrimp i'm keeping their
jobs alive so you're looking for a
little bit of hope right now
everybody's looking for a little bit of
hope because it's not just
the nina compton restaurant this is i'm
fighting for many people that don't have
a voice
that are you know in their kitchens
right now just trying to make things
work
now the restaurant coalition says its
effort has already prompted thousands of
calls to capitol hill
and a third of congress in fact has
signed on to co-sponsor this bill
and that is crucial right now because
another round of stimulus spending
is being negotiated and all of these
restaurant owners argue
any money they receive as nina compton
mentioned isn't just a stimulus for them
it's a direct infusion of money to all
of their clients in the community as
well
jeff all right thanks a big story that's
not going anywhere right now errol
barnett
you can hear more of his conversation
with chefs tom colecchio and nina
compton on today's cbs this morning
podcast